[Música]
boa tarde a todos
no auge dos meus vinte e poucos anos eu
me deparei com a situação e com a
conversa que foi muito preciosa pra mim
eu achando que eu podia morando com os
pais podia fazer o que eu queria dizer
dar satisfação à antônio e chamou de
seguinte meu filho eu percebi que você
quer independência
sabe quando você vai ter isso
quando você paga as suas contas ela fala
apesar de parecer dura ela foi
extremamente preciosa o que fazer eu
quero ser independente
algum tempo depois estava tinha alugado
um apartamento e isso fui ao
supermercado para minha primeira compra
estou lá eu comprando ovos ok
e como eu aprendi eu estava olhando não
tinha nenhum quebrado
ok olhando uma um todo cuidado quando
foi lá pelo décimo uma pessoa se
aproxima de mim o seguinte se você me
permite você pode fazer isso muito mais
fácil é a seguinte você vir aqui ó
você vê todos os fundos os jogos
aquela pessoa que nunca conheci nunca
tinha visto me ofereceu gratuitamente
algo muito poderoso que era poder ver o
mundo de uma forma diferente e aquela
economia daqueles cinco minutos me
permitiu fazer um exercício constante
pra ver o mundo de uma forma melhor e
mais ampla e mais preciosa e com a
importância é importante eu também posso
fazer o que ela fez
naquele momento ela me liberou de uma
forma extraordinária
ela me fez olhar pra alguma coisa que eu
já tinha tinha perdido aquela forma mas
que poderia fazer diferente então o
quanto eu sou grato
aquele ser que por alguns minutos me
liberou de uma forma extraordinária
essa história segue a vida por vários
aspectos e o que tem mais é me deparado
no exercício da atividade é de encontrar
líderes que conseguem de uma forma
fantástica fazer com que os seus
liderados e chegue algo diferente porque
é importante falar de liderança nessa
questão as empresas
elas pedem ajuda liderar nos tempos
atuais é muito diferente do que no
passado
e olha que dado interessante essa
pesquisa dá da rei 86% ficam nos
ambientes porque elas confiam o seu
líder 79% que tem clareza de objetivos
de propósito e 77% porque tenta abortar
desenvolvidos querem crescer
essa dinâmica da nova geração e quando
você olha para o mundo corporativo para
o mundo do esporte você vai verificar
quem está trazendo mais resultados das
empresas
e outro detalhe importante é
simplesmente trazer o melhor resultado é
como você traz esses resultados e aqui
se você perguntar se as pessoas que você
lidera as pessoas que um dia você vai
liderar você confia no seu líder
que resposta seria essa isso seria
importante até de acordo com a natureza
extremamente importante
agora o que você o que nós estamos
construindo para merecer a confiança do
outro
isso me deu e faz olhar no tempo eu vou
pedir para que vocês peguem carona
pensando nas histórias de vocês e se
possível apaixone pela suas histórias
eu estava lá com 17 anos era menor
aprendiz do banco do brasil e um dia o
gerente operacional
eu quero te colocar uma uma
responsabilidade
quero que a partir de amanhã você abre o
banco 17 anos não podia né
mas ele ele falou assim ah só que eu
tenho que ter convicção de que você vai
fazer
o que eu estou colocando como regra é
possível eu queria ser merecedor daquela
conversa aqui no meu líder falar quando
você vira naquela esquina que você olha
para o banco se tiver o vigia você vem
aqui abre se não tivesse vai na padaria
espera chegar alguém aí você entra e foi
assim que eu consegui a confiança
daquele livre que me impulsionou cada
vez melhor porque terá responsabilidades
e merecida daquela confiança fazia toda
a diferença do mundo e agora ao longo do
tempo a gente vai perceber outras coisas
estão conectadas esses líderes
extraordinários e aí tem uma outra
pergunta fundamental
você está preparado para lidar com a
diversidade é porque já ouviu e aqui é
muito fácil para essa enquete você já
foi liberado para por um líder ou nesse
momento no passado que não era
respeitoso com você
quem já teve esse líder que conhece a
história levanta a mão
se for lá tem muita gente
seria importante ser respeitado por
porque você é pelo seu melhor para que
você possa pudesse lidar com essa
diversidade que vai olhando a nossa
própria trajetória de construção a gente
vai tendo algumas formas de que são
impeditivos de você valorizar o que é
diversidade no mundo dos negócios no
mundo corporativo e eólica mente isso
vai trazer uma responsabilidade para nós
por exemplo alguém chega fácil aqui que
que morena bonita que loira bonita
quando fala do mundo mais humanizada
fazei que mulher bonita porque aquele
adjetivo ele que poderia diferenciar ele
é uma forma discrimina
então a gente precisa de um mundo 100%
ou mais de 100% humano
os ambientes corporativos ambiente que
está vivendo é tá trazendo contudo que
está vivendo algo que nos exige um novo
posicionamento
pra isso
você tem sentido na sua família no seu
ambiente de trabalho na universidade
apenas um número ou você é algo que
pertence algo muito precioso e muito
grandioso
se você chegar e perguntar para os
médicos sem fronteiras não fosse eu
pertenço algo extraordinário
os líderes que diferenciam dos demais
eles fazem com que as pessoas
pertencentes algo maior do que elas
sobre tudo aquilo que você faz na sua
vida no seu trabalho traz um significado
da sua vida
isso me fez lembrar uma situação ela
real por questões éticas não vou
compartilhar o nome da empresa e é
impactante uma paciente terminal de um
câncer agressivo
ela recebeu um tratamento a terapia que
prolongou a vida dela por mais tempo
chega num momento que é o momento mais
pro final desse dessa terapia e que ela
percebendo que aquele circo estava por
concluir
ela chama os médicos enfermeiros e
pergunta seguinte eu queria saber quem
são as pessoas que que produzem esse
medicamento aqui porque eu preciso
agradecê los porque joga se você precisa
agradecê los
a gente vai procurar a empresa
procuraram e é convidada ela tratar num
evento importante mais de 500 pessoas e
se ela convidada para ter uma fala de
três minutos
ela entra e eu queria conhecer vocês
porque o tratamento com o medicamento
que vocês têm de distribuir me permitiu
mais seis meses de vida que significou a
oportunidade de ver a minha filha se
formando agora imagina como que isso é
extraordinário para aquelas pessoas que
comercializando produzindo o trabalho
naquele medicamento você cria um
significado e como as empresas ainda não
enxergaram essa possibilidade
os líderes extraordinários fazem isso
fazem questão de fazer isso agora
quem aqui teve um líder que fiz que
estão desenvolver seu potencial
direcionar o seu potencial por seu
melhor
se vocês me permitem aqui eu quero
compartilhar um potencial que eu tive a
oportunidade de conhecer e conviver é a
luciana e naquela ocasião do curso foi a
economia foram cinco anos eu morava numa
cidade de francisco morato trabalhava em
são paulo cidade onde aí era um traje um
trânsito relativamente complicado mas
nunca achava que aquele era um problema
claro objetivo e quatro horas por noite
pegava quatro horas de trânsito não tudo
certo
ele terminou na sexta feira cheguei na
faculdade e não tinha ninguém
como toda a aluna se puxa legal pra casa
descansar eu queria
nisso entra professor fábio a gente
começa a conversar
ele viria para fazer adilson adicional
chamado alemã alemão se leva uma vida
difícil
é difícil não entrar nessa minha colega
luciana ela é tetraplégica escreve com a
boca é uma das pessoas mais
extraordinárias respectiva cuidar de
conhecer além de ela ser uma líder tinha
um pai uma família que apoiava para que
ela usasse o melhor do seu potencial
até aquele momento não tinha a percepção
e consciência de que a luciana foi e me
dava naquele primeiro passo quando
entrava na sala de aula e oferecia
gratuitamente um sorriso e olhar
luminoso e aquilo me dá uma energia
fantástica ela foi melhor aluno em todas
as
minas e recentemente o reencontrei
luciano foi lá buscar na no facebook
onde está luciana trabalhando e napoli
ela até dependente mas é a pessoa mais
independente que eu tive oportunidade de
conhecer líderes potencializam e fazem
com que as pessoas têm essa
traga o seu melhor agora quanto os
líderes tiveram oportunidade de você se
desenvolver
emocionalmente intelectualmente quanto
de fato de colocarem em situações que
você poderia oferecer o melhor ou se de
repente você colocar na situação e aqui
não deu certo e você teve uma derrocada
na carreira
os bons líderes e se preparam se
respeitam até pra dizer não pra você
quando você ainda não está preparado e
vai ter argumentos contundentes para que
você possa compreender isso e agora
justiça é alguma coisa importante
fundamental na nossa trajetória
você já ouviu de que o seu líder algum
líder foi injusto
já ouviram se já ouvira porque o que
estava sendo contratado não era estava
sendo entregue
não há transparência na transparência
falar assim do chefe o meu líder eu
quero ir pra outra área totalmente
diferente porque você não fala isso
porque tem receio de se demitir enquanto
estão muito centrados e que não você é o
meu melhor talento e você vai nessa
direção mas eu quero ir naquela direção
enquanto eles respeitam esse processo
agora pra falar de maturidade é ligado a
esse processo de justiça como seria pra
você olhar para profissionais que no
mercado eles têm essa configuração
enquanto ele se aproxima de talentos
para trabalharem com eles
e aqui vale uma justiça ligada a essa
questão da gratidão me fez lembrar
lá na minha
o ensino primário ensino médio que tem
alguns nomes em quatro diferentes hoje
da dona ana
e quem quer a donna donna era merendeira
da escola lá em francisco morato e ainda
tinha uma fila para pegar maria a
merenda estava lá dona ana neves
servindo a casa e parecia que tinha um
túnel aquela fila tinha crianças alegre
passando e continuando alegre
algumas pessoas algumas crianças tal
mail se judas passava como um todo o
tempo ao passar e receber aquele sorriso
da dona ana havia uma transformação
interessante eles passavam está melhor
a dona liderou milhares de pessoas com
aquela ação com aquele sorriso gratuito
mas extremamente poderoso quanto as
organizações não pode usar isso a seu
favor está na recepção em toda o
processo que vai fazer com que você
atenda melhor às pessoas
eu estou trabalhando aqui com a
confiança com a justiça de forma que eu
possa reconhecer o quanto o outro de
contribuição
lá vou eu novamente no facebook encontra
dona ana e vencedor é preciso dizer algo
muito importante que você impacto na
minha vida
você melhorou centenas de dias não
simplesmente por ser dia a menina como
você servir e aí eu tive a triste
constatação a dona recebeu e se esse
comentário
talvez uma meia dúzia de pessoas estou
falando de centenas milhares de pessoas
que passaram pela do nada
a gente quer um mundo diferente
diferentemente melhor mas a prática de
valorizar se grata ao outro
grato esses líderes que lideram a gente
de forma direta e indireta vai fazer
algo totalmente é impulsionado por para
o mundo melhor a gente tá vivendo uma
configuração que a configuração que pede
que a gente seja mais justo que a gente
seja nova geração
seja o brasil do presente e aí se você
tiver um filho e você tivesse uma
conversa com ele
é a pergunta ele traz a seguinte questão
o papai ou mamãe eu quero ser um líder
político
o que você diria para ele porque ele vai
estar com a bola enquanto os líderes
estão no comando estão com a bola mas
repete o comportamento de muita gente e
aí a ideia pensar o seguinte o que que
eu responderia o que eu disse que
responderia responder o seguinte meu
filho na filha seja capaz de construir
uma educação para que o meu neto e
bisneto possa estudar seja capaz de
construir uma saúde tá aqui meu neto
bisneto possa freqüentar porque senão a
gente tá repetindo uma parte importante
da história esses são os livros que
fazem diferença faz diferença porque
porque o mundo pede uma liderança mais
espiritualizada
eu falei de gratidão falei de líder mas
foi um ponto importante
os valores que conectam conectam o líder
aos demais e não estou falando nada a
ver com religiosidade aqui estou falando
de confiança que é uma coisa que você
valoriza
estou falando de respeito eu tô falando
de justiça eu tô falando sentido de
pertencimento eu tô falando do
significado da vida independente de
crença é que você tem alguma
são valores que você admira um livro que
pode fazer com que você de fato faça a
grande diferença pra isso eu quero
aproveitar esse finalzinho deixar aqui
meu muitíssimo obrigado o quanto eu sou
grato a rodrigo que me convidou para
estar aqui com esse rodrigo em 2004 2005
ele foi meu aluno me acompanhou assim
como acompanhar a trajetória dele
agradecer a vocês pelo tempo que você
está dedicando pra refletir lapidar e
aumentar sua percepção de fazer uma
diferença no mundo
posso aqui também
é fazer menção amanhã dia das mães então
as mães presentes né meu muitíssimo
obrigado a mãe dos meus filhos a minha
esposa ea minha mãe dona neusa e porque
eu tô falando disso porque dona neusa
desde meus que me conheço como gente
a gente tinha direitos e deveres como na
nossa como a maioria das casas seu
direito de brincar em seu direito de
ajudar a mamãe arrumar a casa e naquele
momento não tinha nenhuma punição por
trabalho infantil
nós crescemos com esses valores
nós precisamos construir esses valores
para tornar de fato muito melhor
quero deixar aqui no beijo no coração e
sucesso para todos vocês e bem essa
idéia
olha
[Aplausos]
[Música]